[Musique]
AK le père
lou la mre lou que recherch le petit
humain il donc pris dans leur
[Musique]
famille sontant d'orphelin recueill par
des
louves maiscit Fab trans la
léende
[Musique]
tout comme l'espèce humaine les animaux
pratiquent l'adoption chacun leur façon
parfois sans ménagement chez l'homme
l'adoption peut combler un désir
d'enfant ou être signe de générosité
dans la nature elle n'a pas forcément le
même
sens la loi de la jungle est avant tout
celle du chacun pour
soi en pénétrant cet univers nous de
découvrir pouro les
animè sont pas les leurs est-ce un
accident ou un acte
altruiste notre histoire débute au nord
du Kenya dans le parc national
Sourou ici pendant plusieurs années une
jeune liyonne a adopté des bébés
Orix on l'a baptisé camounnac ou celle
qui est béni en Sambourou comme
l'annoncé dans la Bible la prophétie
d'Esaïe le lion et l'agneau coexistent
pacifiquement leur duo est devenu
symbole de paix mais ce comportement
laisse perplexe les
scientifiques habituellement lorix est
la proie des lions camounac elle protège
la jeune antilope volée à ses parents
[Musique]
naturels pourquoi un lion adopte
trait-il une
antilope cela n'a aucun sens en terme
d'évolution puisque la survie de
l'espèce dépend de la reproduction c'est
l'antithèse des idées défendues par
Charles Darwin dans l'origine des
espèces selon le père de la théorie de
l'évolution le but de chaque espèce est
de transmettre ses propres gènes aux
générations
futures lorix ne partage pas le
patrimoine génétique de la lion en
l'élevant kamamunac ne favorise pas pas
son propre succès
reproductif le temps et l'énergie
consacré à l'antilope sont gaspillés
pour sa
[Musique]
subsistance le comportement de kamounac
est loin d'être
isolé malgré le lourd coûp de l'élevage
des petits on observe dans la nature de
nombreux comportements que l'on peut
assimiler à des
adoptions expliquer l'adoption
pourrait-il être le plus grand échec de
la théorie de l'évolution
deux scientifiques israéliensitan Avital
et Eva Jablonka étudient à Jérusalem le
paradoxe de l'adoption dans la nature si
vous aidez ou adoptez un petit qui n'est
pas le vôtre ou avec lequel vous n'êtes
même pas apparenté
génétiquement vous gaspillez beaucoup de
temps et
d'énergie pour investir dans un petit
qui n'est pas porteur de vos
gênes et la théorie de l'évolution
n'explique pas vraiment un acte qui
constitue une perte de temps et
d'énergie
rendons-nous sur la terre des loups
comme le suggère la fiction le
comportement nourricier est très courant
parmi cette
espèce les loups sont des animaux
sociaux qui vivent en meut composés du
couple reproducteur et de leur
progéniture des années
[Musique]
précédentes la société des loups se
caractérise par une division du travail
les membres du clan partagent les T de
chasse de défense de la tanière et
d'élevage des
[Musique]
louftetons la femelle reproductrice met
bas au printemps dans une tanière
souterraine tant que les Louvet ont
moins de 3 semaines elle tient les
autres membres de la meute à l'écart à
ce moment-là seule la louve est
entièrement dédiée à la satisfaction de
leurs
[Musique]
besoins
pendant l'étape de transition entre 5 et
10 semaines les loufau passent du lait à
une nourriture solide à cet âge ils
apprennent à identifier ceux qui
composent leur
[Musique]
famille toute la meute s'occupe d'eux
collectivement y compris les jeunes
adultes chaque loup leur fait un brin de
toilette et s'assure qu'ils sont bien
nourr leur développement physique et
social progresse jusqu puisse suivre les
membres de la famille à la
chasse quelle que soit leur place dans
la meute les loups peuvent s'emparer de
la nourriture d'un
a chacun défend agressivement sa
pitance
mais les louftau font exception mâles et
femelles sont extrêmement tolérants à
leur
égard les petits ont un accès illimité à
la carcasse du
SER lorsque les louftau ont encore faim
ils demandent de la nourriture en
léchant le museau des adultes si son
estomac est plein le loup ainsi
sollicité régurgitera des aliments pour
le
petit
[Musique]
pourquoi ces loups adultes
s'occupent-ils de leurs jeunes frères et
sœurs ayant atteint leur maturité
sexuelle ils pourrai mettre au monde
leur propre
progéniture il semblerait que ces jeunes
loups aient peu de chance d'élever avec
succès une portée à
eux l'habitat des loups est si rude
qu'ils ont intérêt à demeurer sous la
protection des parents alors en
attendant de s'en sortir tout seul ils
aident la frattererie mais cet
arrangement leur apporte aussi un
bénéfice leurs gênes sont transmis par
le biais de cette
parenté aider sa famille pour propager
ses GES fonctionne aussi chez les
oiseaux on a repéré des assistants
maternels parmi plus de 150 espèces dans
des conditions sociales et écologiques
très
varié nous voici près de CRA dans l'est
de l'Australie le bois d'eucalyptus du
parc cell abrite une espèce d'oiseau au
comportement singulier les craves
d'Australie contrairement à la plupart
des jeunes oiseaux qu tend le nid dès
qu'ils peuvent voler de leurs propres
ailes ceuxci reste auprès de leurs
parents jusqu'à l'âge de 3 ou 4
ans tous les membres du groupe se relent
pendant l'incubation puis pour alimenter
les
[Musique]
poussins
ces oiseaux se nourrissent d'insectes et
de graines qu'il déniche dans les
litières d'herbes et de feuilles en
raison de régulière sécheresses la
nourriture se fait
rare dans ces âpres conditions la
solidarité familiale semble être la plus
adéquate des stratégies parentes
ses parents CRAV serai incapable
d'élever une nouvelle couvée sans
assistance il faut au minimum se oiseaux
pour élever plus d'un jeune par
an comme chez les loups les perspectives
reproductives sont faibles pour les
jeunes tant qu'ils ne sont pas matures
favoriser la survie de leur fraterie
pourrait être le plus sûr moyen de
transmettre leur
gène quand ils sont ad d'autres jeunes
les assisteront à leur tour c'est ce que
les biologistes appellent l'altruisme
réciproque vous me faites une faveur et
je vous en fais une en
retour selon Eva Jablonka ils auront
acquis d'ici là une plus grande
expérience des soins
parentaux en prodiguant des soins les
assistants exercent leurs compétences
parentales et deviennent ainsi plus
habiles et meilleurs parents quand ils
procrent à leur tour ils ne sont pas en
train de diminuer leur propre succès
reproductif au contraire il
l'améliore jusqu'ici tout va bien la
théorie de l'évolution semble
s'appliquer si les parents de
substitution sont de la famille du petit
adopté mais qu'en est-il lorsque ce
n'est pas le
cas ces petites rousseroles des roseaux
s'occupent d'un jeune
coucou leur bébé adoptif tellement
grossi que le nid supporte difficilement
son poids le nourrir et le soigner leur
demande de lourds
[Musique]
efforts non seulement ce petit ne leur
est pas apparenté mais il a de surcroix
éliminé leur propres descendan en
éjectant les œufs hors du
nid
[Musique]
du point de vue du Coucou l'opération
est un véritable
succès mais pourquoi ces parents
adoptifs dépenseraient-ils toute leur
énergie à élever ce meurtrier ça n'a pas
de sens selon Darwin en réalité les
parents adoptifs ont été bernés un
coucou adulte a déposé un de ses œufs
dans leur nid en profitant de leur
inaptitude à reconnaître leur propre
progéniture dans la nature cette
mésaventure survient fréquemment et pas
toujours de la part des parents si une
véritable adoption implique une
identification alors il nous faut
comprendre comment les animaux
distinguent leurs petits des autres
lauréa du prix Nobel le naturaliste
Conrad lawence fut l'un des premiers à
travailler sur cette question dans
l'Autriche des années
depuis son plus jeune âge lesois
passionnent lawence petit garçon il
voulait devenir l'une d'entre elle n'y
parvenant pas il décida d'en élever et
entreprit de dévoiler les mystères de
leur
[Musique]
comportement avec son collègue Oscar
heinh il nomma empreinte le processus
d'apprentissage qui a lieu très tôt dans
la vie de
l'oison à leur naissance les oiseons
suivent naturellement leur mère la
première chose mouvante
aperçu et si ce n'est pas leur mère mais
un homme et bien ils le suivent quand
même Conrad lawence est ainsi devenue
cette maman de substitution qu'ils
accompagnent
[Musique]
partout la période succédant à
l'éclosion est donc cruciale les
poussins s'attachent à leurs parents et
les parents identifient leurs
poussins les femelles imprègnent leur
petits par la vocalisation et des
signaux chimiques
le
résultat une famille
heureuse l'adoption dans le monde animal
ne serait-elle finalement que le fruit
d'une erreur
d'identification en tous les cas des
études montrent que l'adoption tourne
rarement en faveur de l'adopté s'il est
identifié comme
[Musique]
étranger c'est le cas chez plusieurs
espèces les lions les singes langour ou
les
étourneau
observons de plus près ce qui se passe
chez ces oiseaux grégères vivant au sein
de foules
immensees comme la plupart des volatiles
des étournaux sont
monogam il nichent au sein de colonies
ou en couple isolé dans les trous des
arbres ou d'un simple
mur
la femelle pont entre 5 et 7 que les
deux partenaires couvrent tour à
tour le couple s'occupe des poussins à
deux tant que rien ne brise cet
équilibre les étournau sont la proie de
redoutable prédateurs qui partagent leur
territoire
les autours des palombes chassent le
plus souvent dissimulé à l'affu dans les
branchages notre femelle est maintenant
veuve un autre mâle ne tarde pas à lui
faire la cour
elle fe tout d'abord l'indifférence mais
il
s'obstine il a bientôt gain de cause et
s couple avec
elle
cela ne veut pas dire que le nouveau
maître du niid va adopter la descendance
de son
prédécesseur il n'est pas le géniteur
des ufs existants et commet un
infanticide en les jetant hors du
nid au lieu d'attendre que les poussins
de la couvée précédente prennent leur
envol le malâ les tue et provoque ainsi
une ovulation de la
femelle
sa stratégie a fonctionné sa partenaire
a produit une couvée de remplacement
dont il est le
géniteur parallèlement pour l'espèce
humaine deux psychologue canadien d
Wilson ont fait une troublante
découverte avant 2 ans les enfants
élevés avec des beaux parents seraient
100 fois plus susceptible de mourir de
mort violente que ceux vivant avec leurs
parents naturels
les beaux parents sont
traditionnellement dépints comme cruel
mais h navital est prudent concernant le
lien entre l'infanticide humain et nos
origines
animales lorsqu'un lion mâle tue les
petits d'une femelle parce qu'il ne sont
pas les siens mais ceux du précédent Mâ
du
groupe c'est une
adaptation mais si un paire de
substitution chez les humains blesse
d'une façon ou d'une autre un enfant qui
n'est pas le sien il n' tia aucun
bénéfice il n'aura pas plus d'enfants
pour autant si l'homme vivait encore
dans une situation naturelle cet acte
pourrait être bénéfique mais ce n'est
plus le cas pour l'homme il n'y a plus
de continuité tis qu'un animal peut
perpétuer sa ligée de cette façon
aujourd'hui un be père abusif finirait
en prison dans le monde des Babou il en
est tout
autrs ce queous réel d'adoption hors du
cercle familial sont rares chez les
primates on trouve surtout des cas de ce
que l'on pourrait nommer adoption
forcée il débute souvent par
l'enlèvement d'un jeune puis se
transforme en adoption à long
terme dans les sociétés de primat les
bébés se révèlent être des outils
politiques et sociaux
[Musique]
importants ici dans l'ouest de l'Arabie
Saoudite quelques 400 babouins amadrias
vivent à proximité de la ville de Taif
dans le massif
sarawat ils routent autour d'une
décharge où ils viennent régulièrement
chercher de quoi se
nourrir babouin partage ce domaine avec
un groupe de chiens
sauvages ces singes disposent d'un
système social organisé autour des
adultes mâles chaque babouin possède son
propre
harême il veille jalousement sur ses
femelles s'assurant par la force qu'elle
reste sous son
contrôle le Mâ dominant passe la plupart
de son temps à surveiller de prè ses
femelles surtout celles qui sont en
chaleur la hiérarchie des femelles
correspond à leur ordre d'arrivée dans
le
[Musique]
harem lorsqu'un mâle adulte trouve une
femelle à sa convenance il l'épouille
pour tisser des liens
affectif les femelles conçoivent des
petits et le babouin consolide ainsi son
groupe pour posséder une femelle les
jeunes mâles doivent entrer en
concurrence avec leur congénère de
violent combat éclate quand un mâle
tente de s'éclipser avec la belle d'un
autre
à pleine maturité un adulte peut peser
quelques 25 kg soit le double du poids
d'un adolescent voilà pourquoi les jeun
Mâ ESS rarement de voler les femelles
des mâles dominants pour constituer leur
[Musique]
har il se fixe une cible plus facile
ravir des bébés à leur
mère cette mère élorée désire récupérer
son petit mais elle n'ose pas se
confronter au mal
elle appelle son groupe à l'IDE mais
personne ne vient
ver ce bébé de 4 mois est en fait un JEE
m mais quand il s'agit d'un bébé femelle
l'enlèvement se transforme souvent en
adoption permanente le mâle prend alors
soin de la petite jusqu'à ce qu'elle
soit sexuellement mature elle deviendra
la femelle dominante de son
harême malgré tout cette mère ne perd
pas espoir elle attend que le Mâ relâche
sa garde elle détourne son attention en
lui faisant des avances
sexuel mais c'est un
piège
et elle attrape son
bébé cette fois-ci l'adoption a
échoué la volonté de créer une famille
est une pulsion irrépressible
serait-elle responsable de comportement
étr dans le massif sarawat se déroule
d'autres kidnapping les babouins
adoptent des
chiens
[Musique]
ces incidents sont un reflet des
enlèvements juvéniles ils débutent de la
même façon par le vol des
[Musique]
chiot
après cet épisode violent les chiots
grandissent au sein de la famille de
babouin ils se nourrissent avec eux à la
décharge escortent le groupe et dorment
même à leur
[Musique]
[Rires]
côté on voit même les baboins épouiller
les chiens et jouer avec eux un signe de
leur complète intégration car les
baboins ne s'épouillent qu'entre membres
de la même
famille les chiens deviennent un peu les
animaux de compagnie des singes ils
défendent leur famille adoptive contre
les autres chiens et la nuit venue monte
la
[Musique]
garde ces enlèvements possèdent une FA
heureuse
loin des montagnes d'Arabie Saoudite
dans le centre de recherche sur les
primates des Caraïbes le kidnapping des
bébés s'achève souvent plus
tragiquement les M macaque de l'île Koo
Santiago au large de puertoico doivent
protéger leur petit de l'instin maternel
débordant des autres
femelles Dario mastripier de
l'Université de Chicago est spécialiste
du comportement maternel chez ses
sing leur intérêt pour les nourrons déb
trèsôt à an les jeunes femelles sont
déjà très intéressé par les bébés alors
que les jeunes mâles ne s'intéressent
pas du tout au nourrisson et l'intérêt
des femelles demeure élev tout au long
de leur existence le fait qu'elles soi
jeune ou vieille enceinte ou mère d'un
nourriisson n'a aucune importance elles
aimeront toujours les bébés et saisiront
l'opportunité d'en approcher un de le
toucher et d'interagir avec
lui les MRES ma ne sont pas favorables à
ses interactions car ell risqu de se
transformer en enlèvement les femelles
agitent leur queue et émettent des
grognements et des babillages en
s'approchant des nourrissons ces signaux
amicaux sont destinés à rassurer les
mers à les rendre plus
tolérantes la société des macaques
s'organise autour de groupe de femelles
les femelles dominantes leurs filles et
petites filles forment le sommet de
cette pyramide hiérarchique
les petits se rangent immédiatement
derrière leur
m placé à la base de cette pyramide
sociale cette femelle sans enfant
convoite les nourrissons des
autres sa tentative d'enlèvement avorte
en voyant approcher la mère du bébé elle
le pose à terre puis va saluer le bébé
de la femelle dominante en remuant la
queue et en
vocalisant elle est loin d'être la seule
à s'intéresser au
nourrissons pendant 3 mois chaque année
la vie de cette société de macaque
tourne exclusivement autour des bébés
les mâles eux ne s'en souci
guerre il les évite même soigneusement
ainsi que leur
mère
il n'ont rien à faire si ce n'est
attendre la prochaine saison des
amours l'instinct maternel de ces singes
est extrêmement développé le bébé de
cette mère est mort depuis plusieurs
jours déjà mais elle se refuse à le
lâcher
[Musique]
la forte pulsion maternelle des femelles
esté naire car leurs bébés naissent
incompétents pour survivre dans la
nature ils ont besoin d'une constante
attention les macaques sont sélectionné
pour leur capacité à prodiguer ses soins
vouloir toucher enlacer ou parfois
adopter les bébés pourrait être une
conséquence de ce puissant
instinct l'adoption permanente qui voit
un nourrisson adopté et élevé de façon
durable par un individu autre que sa
mère est très rare d'un point de vue
évolutif c'est probablement un accident
une erreur cela pourrait être le produit
du fait que les femelles comme nous
l'avons dit sont très intéressées par
les bébés et que parfois ell ne manque
pas une opportunité d'élever un autre
nourrissant qu'elles ont vu
abandonner cette sensibilité élevée
vis-à-vis des nourrissons permet à ces
femelles de faire de bonnes m mais cette
médaille a un revers le bien-être des
bébés n'est pas toujours le premier
souci des jeunes un peu comme si elle
jouait à la poupée
comme chez les babouins être manipulé
par d'autres individus et source de
risque majeur pour les
nourrissons pour cette raison les
femelles macaques sont extrêmement
vigilantes elles Ess général d'éviter
que les autres femelles même celles de
rang élevé ne se saisissent de leur bébé
quand elles échouent les conséquences
peuvent être
fatal cette jeune femelle de 2 ans est
la demisœur de ce nouveau
[Musique]
neé
elle a réussi à subtiliser le bébé à sa
mère mais elle n'est pas à son aise
craignant peut-être les représailles de
la part des autres femelle du
groupe
[Musique]
une issue tragique menace son envie de
jouer à la maman la face du petit est
couverte de coupure et de bleu preuve
qu'elle ne sait pas encore comment le
porter et surtout sans l' elle est
incapable de le
nourrir
[Musique]
cette mère maladroite a sans doute
amélioré sa compétence parentale mais
cette adoption est un désastre pour le
[Musique]
bébé il mourra d'ici quelques jours à
moins que sa mère biologique ne
réussisse à le
[Musique]
secourir dans le règne animal l'adoption
est souvent vu comme une aberration
cependant dans le centre de la Pologne
un comportement récemment analysé fait
exception chaque année au printemps des
centaines de goélcendrés rejoignent les
îles clairsemées de la rivière
vistoula après avoir hiverné en Europe
de l'Est ces Goélan retournent là où ils
sont nés pour s'y reproduire ces oiseaux
grégères nichent au sein de colonies qui
comptent jusqu'à 100
individus durant les derniers jours
d'avril les femelles pondent entre un et
TR
œufs après une vingtaine de jours
d'incubation les deux premiers poussins
éclosent à quelques heures d'écart le
trè UF lui peut éclore un à 2 jours plus
tard ce qui nous le verrons est un réel
désavantage Monica et Darius bukasinski
travaillent au centre polonais de
recherche écologique depuis plusieurs
années ils étudient les habitudes
reproductives de ces
oiseaux
pour suivre la piste des poussins il
marque la tête de l'aîné d'une couleur
jaune et celle du second de
rouge
enfin le dernier nez se voit teintter de
bleu les poussins sont couv pendant une
semaine l'un des parents les surveille
jusqu'à ce qu'il soit assz fort pour
voler pendant cette période
d'apprentissage il rest près du nid où
ils sont
nourris
le problème du poussin bleu débute là
ses frères aînés ont une tête d'avance
plus fort que lui ils sont toujours les
premiers
[Musique]
àassasier si la saison est pauvre en
nourriture les chances de survie du am
sont minces pire encore si ses parents
sont
inexpérimentés le poussin bleu ne fait
que picorer les
restes ces derniers nés abandonnent
fréquemment leur parents ils quittent le
nid et partent en quête d'une nouvelle
famille d'accueil dans la
colonie elin sollicite lui-même
l'adoption un phénomène rarissime dans
la nature et lourd de conséquence car
son périple n'est pas sans péril il
pourrait être capturé par un oiseau de
proie emporté par la rivière voire même
dévoré par d'autres goél les moîrieuses
voisines des goél cendré sont
particulièrement agressives envers les
poussins
étrangers notre poussin a trouvé une
nouvelle famille dans les dunes la
question est de savoir sil accepté par
ses frères et sœurs
adoptifs mais surtout par leurs
parents il hésite avant
d'approcher ce couple ne lui est pas
familier mais sa tentative d'intégration
semble
réussie il est nourri parmi les les
autres
poussins ce phénomène est loin d'être
unique chez les Goé cendré Monica et
Darius ont observé chaque année un tel
nombre d'adoptions que selon eux il ne
peut s'agir
delesis
descendr l'adoption est
adaptative car il est difficile de
croire qu'un phénomène qui se produit à
une t fréquence dans ces colonies soit
le fruit du
hasard la structure génétique des GO
cendrés a révélé des relations de
parenté parmi ces colonies d'oiseau
elle pourrait favoriser
l'adoption et signifier que ses
bénéfices sont supérieurs à son
coou
ce comportement d'adoption chez ces
oiseaux passe de génération en
génération comment pourrait-il être
transmis est-ce génétique
est tout comme les cycles d'abus sont
répétés dans les familles certains
scientifiques tel qu'a Jablonka pensent
que la tolérance pourrait être transmise
aux jeunes par ses
parentses poussins étrangers ne vous
dérangent pas vous n'êtes pas très
agressif avec eux vos poussins voi ce
comportement et quand ils grandiront ils
seront eumêm plus toérant des poussins
étrangers ou par exemple si vous enlevez
activement des jeunes ce comportement de
kidnapping sera aussi socialement appris
par vos petits qui doivent l'observer
pour l'expérimenter s'ils doivent le
pratiquer plus tard dans leur vie si les
poussins apprennent ce comportement de
leurs parents que se passe-t-il si l'on
place un uf de moitriilleuse dans le nid
d'un Go
cendré les sont en train d'exprimenter
cette
hypothèse AD moitrieuses seront-elles
tolérantes envers les poussins
auront-elles assimilé l'art de
l'adoption pratiqué par leurs parents
d'accueil pour le savoir rendez-vous
dans quelques
années chez l'homme comme chez l'animal
le désir de fonder une famille est un
instinct puissant mais l'histoire non
achevée des goéancendré laisse une
question en suspens peut-on parfois
considérer l'adoption comme un acte de
bonté peut-elle être vraiment
altruiste Darwin lui-même s'est
intéressé à l'altruisme des insectes
sociaux leur observation avait presque
saaborder sa théorie de
l'évolution chez les abeilles les
fourmis et les guêpes certains membres
de la communauté consacrent leur vie
entière à élever la progéniture de
quelqu'un
d'autre les guep polistes construisent
des nids avec de la patte à papier elles
vont chercher du bois le marche puis
avec cette matière construisent des
albéoles
hexagonales un nouveau nid est fondé au
printemps par une ou plusieurs femelles
l'une de ces femelles occupe la position
dominante et devient la reine paraissant
plus grosse elle est la mère des
femelles ouvrières et se spécialise dans
la pomte des
ufs c'est la tâche principale de la
reine qui quitte RAR
les ouvrières toutes femelles
construisent et entretiennent le nid
mais leur priorité est d'élever les
petits de la
[Musique]
reine s'occuper de cette nurcerie est
une Rud de corvé les gu polistes sont
des prédateurs elles chassent des
insectes les brois puis les régurgit
pour alimenter les
larmes
elle livre aussi des gouttelettes d'eau
à l'entrée de leurs
albéoles puis elles battent des ailes
pour créer un courant d'air
frais l'eau s'évapore et soulage les
larves de la chaleur
estivale
on ne peut pas dire que ces maires de
substitution ne payent pas de leur
personne pour élever ces
jeunes Darwin justifia l'altruisme des
insectes sociaux comme un soutien à la
famille élargie leur sacrifice n'est pas
une perte de temps sa théorie est donc
sauve le professeur
stanoilazzi spécialiste des insectes
sociaux à l'université de Florence nous
explique
pourquoi
le comportement
altruiste est celui d'un animal qui
renonce à sa propre
reproduction pour augmenter la
reproduction d'un autre
individu dans le cas des ouvrières
elles ont un lien de parenté plus fort
avec leur sœur c'estàdire les filles de
la
reine qu'UR avec leurs propres
enfants et cette situation fait que d'un
point de vue évolutif les ouvrières
préfèrent renoncer à leur propre
reproduction pour aider leur mère à
élever leur sœur en plus grand
nombre comme les loups et les CRAV les
gu C ell-mêm en assistant leur r leurs
GES seront transmis à la prochaine
générationantmefie à échelle pour les
générations futures on ne peut pas dire
que ces actes altruistes soi
délibérés la bonté intentionnelle est
difficile à détecter dans la nature pour
démontrer qu'elle existe il faut prouver
qu'un animal peut se mettre à la place
d'un
autre on pense que certains animaux
intelligents les chimpanzés et les
dauphins par exemple font preuve
d'empathie ils comprennent que d'autres
peuvent éprouver des désirs des peurs ou
des souffrances comme les leurs agir en
fonction à Rangiroa dans l'archipel
polynésien des tamutou vit une
communauté sédentaire de dauphin
tursops ils forment une société
hiérarchisée faite de sous-groupes les
femelles et les bébés les mâles et enfin
des groupes mixtes de
jeunes
les requins à pointe blanches sont parmi
leurs plus dangereux prédateurs à la
première occasion ils attaqueront et
tueront les bébés
turciops des dauphins mal sont
conscients de cette
menace une patrouille se forme pour
éloigner le requin du groupe de femelles
et de
nouveau-né des dauphins harcèlent le
requin à plusieurs leur stratégie est de
le désorienter en nageant autour de lui
dans toutes les
directions leurs efforts coordonnés
portent enfin leurs fruits et le requin
à pointe blanche abandonne la
partie un comportement complexe comme
celui-ci semble indiquer que les
turciops ont une compréhension des
autres ils sont sensibles à leur
vulnérabilité et agissent en
conséquen un étrange incident observé
parmi cette communauté de Rangiroa va
dans le sens de cette
supposition de temps en temps des
sténelles à longbec quittent leur
habitat du grand large pour pénétrer les
e côtièr des tursops on les distingue
par leur petite taille leurs rostre plus
allongé et des flan teintés de
blan une jeune sténelle a été découverte
parmi cette communauté de tursops elle a
peut-être perdu son groupe lors de la
traversée des eaux de Rangiroa ou bien a
été enlevé par les dauphin
turciops dans tous les cas privée de sa
mère elle n'aurait pu survivre longtemps
toute
seule
[Musique]
les dauphins semblent l'avoir
adopté les émissions sonores de la
sténelle ne sont pas les mêmes que
celles des turciops alors cette jeune
communique avec sa nouvelle famille
grâce au langage du
corps malgré leur différence physique et
culturelle cette sténelle a été prise en
charge par les turciops qui la soigne et
l'élève
elle s'est même adapté au
différent du Grand
[Musique]
Large à regarder ces dauphins il
semblerait bien que l'Homo sapiens ne
soit pas la seule espèce capable de
prendre en charge le bien-être d'un
orphelin
notre histoire s'achève sur le
territoire des Bonobo nos plus proches
parents génétique avec les
chimpanzés le seul pays où il subsiste
encore
Natur et la République démocratique du
Congo cette espèce en voie de
disparition vit en large groupe dans une
petite zone de forêt vierge sur la côte
sud du fleuve
Congo suite au guerr dans la région des
Grands Lacs nous ne savons pas combien
de Bonobo vivent encore
ici il continuent d'être illégalement
chassés pour leur viande et capturé
comme animaux
domestiqu
dans la société Bonobo les femelles ont
une position dominante et jouent un rôle
central au sein du
groupe l'affection maternelle et le
contact physique sont cruciaux pour le
bien-être psychologique des
bonop
dans cette société matriarcale le
pouvoir des mâles est déterminé par la
position de leur mère ils dépendent
d'elle durant l'enfance mais aussi tout
au long de leur
vie il y a quelques années un orphulina
a été ouvert à proximité de la capitale
Kinshasa pour recueillir les jeunes
singes confisqu au chasseur à son
arrivée chaque bébé est confié à une
nourrice
humaine car sans contact régulier avec
une femelle de leur propre espèce qui
des humains les jeunes Bonobo se
laisserai
[Musique]
dépérir en véritable mère d'accueil ces
femmes congolaises tissent de solides
liens affectif avec les
orphelinsboutzsbout
[Musique]
an
de les bébés apprécient cette attention
de tous les instants mais cette adoption
n'est que
temporaire le but de ces femmes est de
donner au singes la force de réintégrer
ensuite le groupe des
adultes un tel don de soi a longtemps
paru opposé à la férocité du monde
animal
pourtant comme nous l'avons vu chez les
dauphins certains comportements adoptifs
peuvent être qualifiés
[Rires]
d'altruiste c'est
magnifique loin de réfuter la théorie de
l'évolution les comportements d'adoption
la rendent encore plus riche et
fascinante preuve que la loi de la
jungle est compatible avec l'existence
de coopération
d'entraide voire de
[Musique]
[Rires]
sacrifice
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]